okay imagine you're part of an eSports
team that just a few years ago was
playing in the minor leagues and now
you're part of your eSports pinnacle of
competition the world is watching and
talking about you except they're talking
about you for all the wrong reasons
because your org is imploding in a black
hole of drama infighting and national
legal investigations well that's exactly
what's happening to Griffin a Korean
League of Legends team that's having a
hell of a time both on and off the rift
[Music]
okay so this issue quite frankly is a
[ __ ] online a lot of the
information is scattered it's
decentralized on reddit posts in discord
servers social media it's difficult to
verify and there's new info breaking all
the time and that's all part of the
reason that we wanted to tackle this
issue on don't at me to take all that
disparate information and cut to the
heart of the matter now Griffin as a
team is quite a Cinderella story they
formed in 2016 and they made it from
what essentially are the minor leagues
of Korean League of Legends to the lck
which is the main league and they've
continued to kick ass ever since they're
kind of like the Rocky Balboa of Korean
League of Legends now there are two big
names you need to know for this story
the first is CV max he's the ex coach of
the team and has been credited with a
lot of Griffin's success the second is
Joe you know the current asterisk on
current manager of Griffin and I do
apologize if I butchered the
pronunciation of his name now getting on
with the story last month just two weeks
before the League of Legends World
Championship group stage was set to
start it was announced that Griffin and
CV max the coach were mutually parting
ways it's safe to say that for most
people in the scene this was kind of a
shock now after that - Griffin players
Viper and sword seemed to indicate in
interviews that CV max had been lying
about the team in some way during his
personal streams
now those two interviews are in Korean
so unfortunately I have had to rely on
translations from very helpful redditors
that I haven't been able to
independently verify sword's interview
in particular seemed kind of heated
here's the key part at least according
to a translation from a very helpful
redditor quote I think CV max is
spreading lies we like him as a person
so we watch his streams occasionally but
he says a lot of things that bother us
if he was truly the head coach that
loved and cared about us I don't think
he would be engaging in this sort of
behavior we let it slide because it's CB
max
but it is really putting us in an
awkward position so I hope for the sake
of our team and the players he should
distance himself from our team what's
kind of odd here is that from what I've
heard from english-speaking lck fans CV
max actually didn't say anything
negative about Griffon on his personal
streams at all anyways it's at this
point that things really go so CB max
sees the interview with Viper while he's
streaming and starts dropping bombs
about Griffin according to CV max there
was no mutual parting of ways the
manager show straight up fired CV max
said that show told him he had nothing
to do with Griffin's success that they
would have succeeded in the lck with any
coach and it was all just luck on CV
Max's Part C V Max said again according
to a translation that showed disallowed
him from streaming while he was part of
Griffin to prevent CV max from getting
tuned influential or powerful or well
known within Griffin these translations
of CV max's stream really paint a
picture of the manager show allegedly
being jealous of the attention and the
credit that cv max is receiving for
Griffin's meteoric rise from Challenger
roster to one of the best teams in Korea
there are also allegations that show
allegedly tried to strong-arm a young
player named Konami into signing an
allegedly unfavorable contract with a
different team these allegations by the
way are being investigated by Riot Games
KeSPA and yes more than one South Korean
senator now there's gonna be more on
that soon so stay with us there are more
allegations - like a lot more if you
care to actually look them up now it's
worth saying at this juncture that all
of the stuff from CB max's stream is of
course coming from the perspective of CV
Max and from Konami the players moving
on last week still ate the parent
company of Griffin broke their silence
and released an official statement on
the matter according to a translation by
Ashley Kang of
horizon the CEO of still a apologised to
see v-max and acknowledged his
significant contributions to Griffin's
success over the last few years the
still 8 statement also says that they
are conducting their own internal
investigation into everything that's
happened and that it will likely be
released after worlds meanwhile by the
way show is being sued for about twenty
thousand dollars for an unrelated debt
collecting matter according to
translations from a Korean news site but
wait there's more now there are multiple
korean senators involved one of them a
senator by the name of hot a hyung and i
apologize so much if I'm getting that
name wrong apparently heard about
Kenobi's contract he said there could
potentially be criminal charges involved
if it's determined that Griffin or a
member of Griffin coerced or extorted a
minor into signing a contract let alone
an unfavorable or potentially illegal
one that is according to a translation
of a Facebook post that the senator
meant and the translation is from the
lck discord shoutout to you guys the
second senator involved is a guy by the
name of Lee dongsuk once again apologies
for the mispronunciation if there is one
now this gentleman has apparently gone
as far as to propose an amendment to
South Korean law that would require
eSports contracts to be standardized in
some way and first go through the
Ministry of Culture Sports and Tourism
this is according to an automated
translation of a Korean news article in
other words guys this scandal could
change the way eSports contracts are
drafted and implemented in South Korea
forever and if you're interested in
learning more about this scandal there
are a lot more threads to pull on out
there but it's worth saying that while
all of this has been happening the
actual team Griffin has been wrecking
[ __ ] at world's domination from start to
finish in two games straight and Griffin
make up
big statement here when the pressure is
on they show up they show up big and
they have dominated the Le seeds first
seed to take first in the group they won
all but a single group stage match and
face defending world champions IG and
the quarterfinals this Saturday it's an
incredible place to be in for a team
that just over a year ago wasn't even
playing in the lck but unfortunately for
the fans of Gryphon and for the young
men that actually make up the roster
this scandal is all anyone is talking
about oh by the way guys if you're still
watching you must really love our
content and if that is the case well I
have good news for you our
feature-length documentary series the
story of is now in podcast form you can
download it from iTunes or wherever you
get your podcasts there'll be a link in
the description below ok sick all right
let's do it
this is Griffin's screen oh yeah
[Music]
yeah your head east rings oh yeah man
this is what I'm talking about
this is good I cannot see that so I have
to rely on other humans yeah it's
important people people expect it now